In the previous episode of this series, we spent some time with Tilecia Lee, a mom who was drifting between living in her car and sometimes staying with friends or family. In that story, when Tilecia finally started trying to get some help getting into housing or shelter, she began by calling 211. Thank you so much for hoping. How can I assist you today? Yes, me and my 11-year-old son is homeless. Okay. I heard a lot about 211 doing this reporting, not just from Tilecia who called a bunch of times,
在本系列上一集中，我们花了一些时间了解蒂莱西亚·李（Tilecia Lee），一位在车里生活、有时借宿在朋友或家人家里的母亲。在那段故事中，当蒂莱西亚终于开始寻求帮助以解决住房或庇护所问题时，她首先拨打了 211。非常感谢您拨打求助热线。今天有什么我可以帮您的吗？是的，我和我 11 岁的儿子无家可归。好的。我听到很多关于 211 这种求助热线的反馈，不仅来自打了好几次电话的蒂莱西亚，
but from everyone, from homeless people and service providers and advocates. It seemed like 211 was almost always the starting place for people who were looking for help. But mostly when people talked about calling, they were frustrated. They'd say, I called, but it didn't work, or I called, but I didn't get anything. That's how Tileisha felt. In her mind, 2-1-1 and the system were the same thing, and they hadn't come through for her. So what was 2-1-1's role in the system that helps people out of homelessness? And why did it seem like a dead end for so many people? Hi, good morning.
还有所有人，包括无家可归者、服务提供商和倡导者。似乎 211 几乎总是那些寻找帮助的人的第一站。但当人们谈到打电话时，大多都感到沮丧。他们会说，我打了，但没用，或者我打了，但什么也没得到。蒂莱西亚就是这种感觉。在她看来，211 和整个体制是一回事，而它们并没有帮到她。那么，在帮助人们摆脱无家可归的体制中，211 扮演着什么角色？为什么对这么多人来说，它似乎成了一条死胡同？嗨，早上好。
Hi, I'm Katie Mingone. I'm a reporter that's here to... Oh, that's right, Katie. Yeah, are you doing Katie? Good. At the beginning of March, right before everything shut down for the pandemic, I paid a visit That's here to... Oh, that's right, Peter. Are you joking? Good. At the beginning of March, right before everything shut down for the pandemic, I paid a visit to the 211 call center.
嗨，我是凯蒂·明戈尼。我是一名记者，我来这儿是为了……哦，对了，凯蒂。耶，凯蒂你过得怎么样？不错。在三月初，就在疫情导致一切关停之前，我拜访了……哦，对了，彼得。耶，你在开玩笑吗？不错。在三月初，就在疫情导致一切关停之前，我拜访了 211 呼叫中心。
I found answers to those questions, but I also found a whole fascinating world, where the boundaries that separate collar and operator are blurrier than I imagined. This is according to Need, chapter two. In Alameda County, 211 is run by a nonprofit called Eden-Ion-R and is located in the city of Hayward, southeast of Oakland. The main call center room is about the size of an elementary school classroom. It has brown carpet, fluorescent lighting, and nonprofit energy. There's a little coffee station and a mini fridge, and seven operators at desks,
我找到了这些问题的答案，但也发现了一个完全迷人的世界，在那里，来电者和接线员之间的界限比我想象的要模糊。这是“按需分配”第二章。在阿拉米达县，211 由一家名为 Eden-I&R 的非营利组织运营，位于奥克兰东南部的海沃德市。主呼叫中心大约有一个小学教室那么大。那里有棕色的地毯、荧光灯，充满了非营利机构的氛围。这里有一个小咖啡站和一个小冰箱，桌旁坐着七名接线员，
all wearing headsets. As the day goes on, there will be moments when they are all talking at once. You need to call them between 7pm. I need to Friday. Not all of the people who call 2 and 1 are homeless but most of them are low income. It could be just having a crisis going on. You know the ends are not meeting for this month. The ends are not going to meet for the next few months or someone's had an injury on the job. That's an operator named Roshana Robinson and she says people call 2-1-1
他们都戴着耳机。随着一天的进行，会有一段时间他们所有人都在同时说话。你需要让他们在晚上 7 点之间打电话。我需要到星期五。并非所有拨打 211 的人都无家可归，但其中大多数人都是低收入群体。可能只是遇到了危机。你知道这个月的收支不能相抵。接下来的几个月收支也无法相抵，或者有人在工作中受伤了。那是接线员罗沙娜·罗宾逊（Roshana Robinson），她说人们拨打 211
looking for help paying their electric bill and helping rent, help doing all kinds of things that money can solve if you've got it. Only me the county is someone I can help here. Just a note here, any collars you hear in this episode have given us their explicit permission to play their call. Although, in some cases, we've taken out their names. I would like to know what you all know in about it and give a wash and see. I'm 93 years old. One 93-year-old woman who called while I was there
是为了寻求支付电费、房租的帮助，以及寻求如果手头有钱就能解决的各种事情的帮助。只有我县有人能在这里帮忙。在此说明一下，本集中的任何来电者都已明确授权我们播放他们的通话录音。但在某些情况下，我们隐去了他们的名字。我想知道你们对这件事有什么了解，并请人洗个澡看看。我今年 93 岁。我在那儿时打来电话的一位 93 岁老妇人
said last time she walked to the laundromat, she nearly fainted from exhaustion. She calls Roshana baby and sometimes sir, which Roshana is completely unfazed by. I'm a washer, hodle and moment. Okay baby, that's right. One moment. Okay, thank you, sir. Oh, you're welcome.
说，上次她走到自助洗衣店时，差一点累得晕过去。她叫罗沙娜“宝贝”，有时叫她“先生”，罗沙娜对此完全无动于衷。我是一名洗涤工，握住并稍等。好的，宝贝，没错。请稍等。好的，谢谢您，先生。哦，不客气。
Roshana couldn't find any organizations that looked like they helped people get appliances, but she gave this woman some phone numbers to try just in case. The vast web of government services and non-profits can be hard to navigate, especially for people who may not have the internet at home. 2-1-1 operators are trying to point callers toward resources that might benefit them, which is why they're officially called phone resource specialists. But with their blessing, I'm going to stick with the less jargonny term operator. Can I just record a little bit while you do the shelter calls? term operator. Early in the day, Hata Gonzales, one of the operators, starts calling shelters in Alameda County to see if they have space available. Thank you very much. Thank you very much.
罗沙娜找不到任何看起来像是能帮人们获得家用电器的机构，但她还是给了这位女士几个电话号码，以防万一。庞大的政府服务和非营利组织网络可能很难摸清，尤其是对那些家里可能没有互联网的人来说。211 接线员正试图将来电者引向可能对他们有益的资源，这就是为什么他们的官方称呼是电话资源专家。但经过他们的允许，我还是用“接线员”这个不那么行话的词。我能在你打庇护所电话时稍微录一点音吗？称呼。一早，接线员之一哈塔·冈萨雷斯（Hata Gonzales）开始给阿拉米达县的庇护所打电话，看它们是否有空位。非常感谢。非常感谢。
One, how can I help you? Okay. One by say. They don't have anything available. How does been an operator at 2-1-1 for 7 years? And she's done these calls so many times that the words come out quick and tonal, almost divorced from meaning. Good morning.
喂，有什么我可以帮您的？好的。一个由...说。他们没有任何空位。哈塔在 211 做接线员已经 7 年了。这些电话她打过太多次，以至于说出的词句变得急促而有音调感，几乎脱离了含义。早上好。
My name is Adam. I'm calling from Alameda County to 1-1. You're checking on shelter space. Okay, thank you. Love it. Okay, thank you. Nothing. A lot of people who call 211 are looking for shelter. And if there are spaces available,
我叫亚当。我从阿拉米达县 211 打来电话。我在查询庇护所空位。好的，谢谢。太棒了。好的，谢谢。没有。许多拨打 211 的人都在寻找庇护所。如果有空位，
the operators can help preserve them a bed. But keeping track of an inventory of shelter beds is more challenging than you might imagine. The number of open beds is always in flux. There are shelters that have 80 beds in the winter and 60 in the summer, and beds that just suddenly pop up in some random church basement. There are separate shelters reserved for victims of domestic violence. There are shelters that take moms with their kids if the kids are under 10, but not over
接线员可以帮他们预留一张床位。但追踪庇护所床位的库存比你想象的更具挑战性。开放床位的数量一直在变动。有些庇护所在冬天有 80 个床位，夏天有 60 个，还有些床位突然出现在某个随机的教堂地下室里。有专门为家庭暴力受害者保留的独立庇护所。有些庇护所接收带孩子的母亲，如果孩子在 10 岁以下，但不接收超过
10. There are currently no shelters in the county that accept fathers with their kids, but there might be one opening soon. How to cause a few more shelters with the same results? Nothing, no space available. So far today, all they have to offer callers is one spot for a mother and two children.
10 岁的。目前该县没有一家庇护所接收带孩子的父亲，但可能很快会有一家开业。哈塔又打了几个庇护所电话，结果都一样。没有，没有空位。到今天为止，他们能为来电者提供的只有母亲和两个孩子的一个名额。
It's hard. It's frustrating. Roshanna told me she got a call recently from a mother who needed shelter for that night and she had nothing to give her. It was on the phone me and I can hear her by straight. She's like, so, huh, what are I going to do? It's nothing. It's nowhere.
这很难。这令人沮丧。罗沙娜告诉我，她最近接到一位母亲的电话，说她需要当晚的庇护所，而她却什么也提供不了。当时我们在通话，我能听出她快崩溃了。她说：“那么，哈，我该怎么办？什么都没有。哪里都没有。”
She's like, so me and my child are literally about to be on the streets tonight. to do is nothing, is nowhere. Like, so me and my child literally about to be on the streets tonight. I wanted to go by her hotel room. I was on the phone with her for 33 minutes, and she was, I know she was staying on the phone with me to think I was gonna give her like her light of hope, and I was hopeless there. Already I was starting to understand why people were always saying I called to one one
她说：“所以我和我的孩子今晚真的要流落街头了。”该怎么办，什么都没有，哪里都没有。就像，我和我的孩子今晚真的要流落街头了。我想去她的酒店房间。我和她通了 33 分钟电话，我知道她一直留在电话里，是以为我会给她带来一线希望，而我在那里感到了绝望。我已经开始明白为什么人们总是说我打了 211
and I didn't get anything. They weren't getting anything because there was nothing to give. Thank you for calling Almina County to one one. How can I help you? Almost colors who want help with something other than shelter, like housing, for example. We'll have to get into the county's coordinated entry system. And this, this was the same system Tileisha had entered. 2-1-1, it turns out, is sort of like a door man for this system.
却什么也没得到。他们什么也没得到，因为根本没有什么可给的。感谢致电阿拉米达县 211。有什么我可以帮您的？几乎想要寻求庇护所以外帮助的来电者，比如住房。都必须进入该县的协调准入系统。而这，正是蒂莱西亚曾进入的系统。事实证明，211 就像是这个系统的门卫。
Opening the door for some people to enter, but not for others. OK, and you're looking for housing? Around 10 a.m., I get to see one of these calls. An operator named Grapri Minhas gets a call from a 24-year-old mother who wants help with housing. First and last name? To get that help, she'll need to go into the coordinated entry system. But whether she makes it in at all depends essentially on how she
为某些人打开大门，却将其他人拒之门外。好的，你在找房子吗？大约上午 10 点，我旁听了这样一通电话。一位名叫加普里·明哈斯（Grapri Minhas）的接线员接到了一位 24 岁母亲的电话，她想寻求住房方面的帮助。名和姓？要获得这种帮助，她需要进入协调准入系统。但她能否成功进入，基本上取决于她如何
answers one question. And where did you guys sleep or stay last night? Capri is screening this caller to determine if she meets the definition of literal homelessness according to the Department of Housing and Urban Development and by extension Alameda County. That's the actual term they use, literal homelessness. You are literally homeless if last night you slept in a shelter or in a place not meant for human habitation, like a tent or a car
回答一个问题。你们昨晚睡在哪儿或住在哪里？加普里正在筛选这位来电者，以确定她是否符合美国住房和城市发展部以及阿拉米达县对“字面意义上的无家可归”的定义。这是他们实际使用的术语，字面意义上的无家可归。如果你昨晚睡在庇护所里，或者睡在不适合人类居住的地方，比如帐篷、汽车
or a broken-down RV. If this is the case, then you get the rubber stamp of literal homelessness, and the operators can pass you along to do a longer interview. In which you'll be asked a bunch more questions about your particular situation and then entered into the system. But here's the kind of maddening thing. Say you used to stay in the car for three months, and then one day you sleep at a friend's
或破旧的房车里，你就是字面意义上的无家可归。如果是这种情况，你就会获得字面意义上的无家可归的盖章认证，接线员就可以把你转过去进行更长时间的访谈。在访谈中，系统会问你一堆关于你具体情况的更多问题，然后将你录入系统。但这就是令人抓狂的地方。假设你在车里住了三个月，然后有一天你睡在朋友
house. But that's the day you happen to call 2-1-1. In that case, you're not literally homeless, according to their definition. And if you're not literally homeless, you can't get into the system at all, which means you can't get help with housing. And this caller, the Capri, is talking to. She seems to realize this. We don't have permission from her to play the recording, so I'll paraphrase what's happening on her end. In response to Caprice's question about where she slept last night, the caller says,
家里。但偏偏那天你打了 211。在这种情况下，根据他们的定义，你不是字面意义上的无家可归。如果你不是字面意义上的无家可归，你就根本无法进入系统，这意味着你无法获得住房方面的帮助。而加普里正在交谈的这位来电者似乎意识到了这一点。我们没有她的授权播放录音，所以我将转述她那边发生的事情。针对加普里关于她昨晚睡在哪里的问题，来电者说：
someone told me that I should tell you I've been sleeping in my car. It's not what somebody told you, it's just where did you sleep last night? To this, the caller says, well, my kids don't sleep in the car, but I do. So last night, where did you sleep? Did you sleep in the car? Did you sleep on the street? Did you sleep in someone's home? Where did you sleep?
有人告诉我，我应该对你说我一直睡在车里。这不是别人告诉你什么的问题，而是你昨晚到底睡在哪儿？对此，来电者说，嗯，我的孩子不住在车里，但我住。所以昨晚你睡在哪儿？你睡在车里了吗？你睡在街上了吗？你睡在别人的家里了吗？你睡在哪儿？
I'm couch surfing, she says. But when there's no room, I go to my car. Okay, so question again, where were you last night? Where did you sleep last night? In my car, in my car. Okay. How long have you been sleeping in your car? Now the color size. Finally, she says, I feel like you guys want a straightforward answer, but I can't give you one. It's pretty
我在到处借宿，她说。但如果没有地方，我就去我的车里。好的，所以再次请问，你昨晚在哪里？你昨晚睡在哪儿？在我的车里，在我的车里。好的。你在车里睡了多久？这时来电者叹了口气。最后她说，我觉得你们想要一个直接的回答，但我给不了。这是一个相当
simple questions, ma'am, and this color situation is complicated and influx, but GrapriPri needs to check a box. Give me one second. I'm going to put you on on hold and I'll see if I can get them on the other line, okay? Gopreat does forward her on, even though it feels unclear to her whether the woman fulfills the criteria or not. The longer interview might reveal that she doesn't need the definition of literal homelessness after all.
简单的问题，女士，这位来电者的处境很复杂且处于变动中，但加普里需要勾选一个选项。请给我一秒钟。我要把你转为保持通话，看看能不能联系到另一条线上的人，好吗？加普里确实把她转接了过去，尽管她自己也不清楚这个女人是否符合标准。较长时间的访谈可能会显示，她其实并不符合字面意义上的无家可归的定义。
She wants to say she's literally homeless, but I think she's actually been staying at a friend's house, where she's going to end up saying that, and then what they're trying to help with this program is individuals who don't have any other resources. I mean, it seems like part of what she was getting hung up on is that the questions sort of didn't account for like nuance. And I understand we need to be more, you know, more patient, but sometimes it's just so difficult because there's just like constantly, like attacking you and you're just asking simple questions, but it's just, so it's like a struggle.
她想说自己字面意义上无家可归，但我觉得她实际上一直住在朋友家，最后她会说出实情，然后这个项目试图帮助的人是那些没有任何其他资源的人。我的意思是，她纠结的部分原因似乎在于，这些问题没有考虑到细微差别。我理解我们需要更有耐心，但有时这真的很困难，因为总是有各种事情向你袭来，而你只是在问简单的问题，但这实在太艰难了。
When Tileisha Lee called 2-1-1 in the last episode, she could truthfully say she was sleeping in her car at the time, which meant she was ultimately allowed to enter the system. But hers was a similarly influx situation. She was often drifting between sleeping in the car and sleeping on someone's floor or couch. Staying with other people like that in a temporary, unstable way drifting between sleeping in the car and sleeping on someone's floor or couch. Staying with other people like that in a temporary, unstable way is often referred to as being doubled up.
上一集中蒂莱西亚·李打 211 时，她可以诚实地说她当时睡在车里，这意味着她最终被允许进入系统。但她的情况同样处于变动中。她经常在睡在车里和睡在某人的地板或沙发上之间漂泊。像这样以临时的、不稳定的方式与其他人住在一起，在睡车里和睡别人地板或沙发间漂泊，
The Department of Education reported that there were about 220,000 students in California who were living doubled up in 2018. That's 220,000 kids plus their parents or guardians that HUD may not be counting as homeless who do not in fact have homes. And when those people call to you on one, they're told they're not literally homeless. People are really good frustrated when you tell them they're not literally homeless and they're like, I am homeless. What do you mean? I'm sleeping on the effing couch and I'm sleeping in my effing car. And I just got let in last night.
通常被称为“寄人篱下”。教育部报告称，2018 年加州大约有 22.0 万名学生寄人篱下。那是 22.0 万名儿童加上他们的父母或监护人，HUD 可能没有将他们算作无家可归者，但他们确实没有家。而当这些人打 211 时，却被告知他们并非字面意义上的无家可归。当人们被告知自己不是字面意义上的无家可归时，他们会非常沮丧，他们会说，我就是无家可归。你什么意思？我特么睡在沙发上，我特么睡在车里。我昨晚才刚被放进来。
But even when people do make it into the coordinated entry system, they don't always get help. I mean, Tilecia had gotten into the system, and she hadn't gotten anything. Roshana seemed unclear on what exactly happens to people after they get in. So I tell them it's a case by case? And so they basically end up on a list.
但即使人们确实进入了协调准入系统，他们也并不总是能得到帮助。我的意思是，蒂莱西亚已经进入了系统，但她什么也没得到。罗沙娜似乎不清楚人们进去之后到底会发生什么。所以我告诉他们这是具体情况具体分析？所以他们基本上最后会在一个名单上。
Is that your understanding? Basically, yeah. Roshana doesn't get to find out what happens to people after they get on the list. But what she does know is that they don't always get housing. And that's because those same people end up calling 2-1-1 again And they're like I already got that I'm already on that list and people for like they're getting sent in a circle There aren't many parts of a bureaucracy that you can actually talk to But you can always talk to someone at 2-1-1 24 hours a day, which means the operators become the target of a lot of frustration
这是你的理解吗？基本上是这样的。罗沙娜无法得知人们上了名单后会发生什么。但她所知道的是，他们并不总能得到住房。这是因为同样这些人最后又给 211 打了电话，他们说：我早就知道了，我已经在那名单上了，人们感觉自己被当成猴耍在原地打转。在官僚体制中，你真正能交谈的部分并不多，但你随时都可以跟 211 的人通话，24 小时全天候，这意味着接线员成了大量沮丧情绪的发泄对象。
Yeah, the yell, cuss you out. Yeah. You're worth punching bags. All of us have been. When people call 2-1-1, they're often already having a really hard day. They might be in the midst of a crisis or a moment of true desperation. And even though colors have to give information like their name and phone number, there's also a certain kind of anonymity. It's fine if the operator hears you in your most vulnerable moment
对，他们大喊大叫，满口脏话。是的。你们成了出气筒。我们所有人都是。当人们拨打 211 时，他们通常已经经历了非常艰难的一天。他们可能正处于危机之中，或者处于极度绝望的时刻。尽管来电者必须提供姓名和电话号码等信息，但某种程度上也存在着匿名性。接线员听到你最脆弱的时刻也没关系，
because your name doesn't mean anything to them. You're just two voices in the dark. Except for sometimes all of a sudden you aren't. Good morning, thank you for calling out to me to county 211. How can I help you? I'm homeless at Alameda County with the two-year-old son. Not the day I was there, but earlier this year when Roshana was still pretty new on the job. She answered a call from someone who sounded familiar. The caller said she and her son were homeless and looking for help.
因为你的名字对他们来说没有任何意义。你们只是黑暗中的两个声音。除了有时突然之间，你不再是了。早上好，感谢致电阿拉米达县 211。有什么我可以帮您的？我在阿拉米达县无家可归，带着一个两岁的儿子。不是我在那儿的那天，而是今年早些时候，罗沙娜刚上班不久的时候。她接听了一个听起来很熟悉的来电。来电者说她和儿子无家可归，正在寻求帮助。
I even like, I sheltered after vibes, from type of like housing, afterwards, I'm like, dad, I get me some resources. But I'm willing to move anywhere that I can get help. Okay, can I? Roshana starts asking her usual questions. Have you called to 111 before? What's your phone number?
我甚至喜欢，我想要避难所之后的氛围，那种住房类型的氛围，之后，我说，爸爸，给我找点资源。但我愿意搬到任何能得到帮助的地方。好的，我可以吗？罗沙娜开始问她常规的问题。你以前打过 211 吗？你的电话号码是多少？
What's your name? My first name is Bill. BEEP. And my last name is BEEP. Now, Urshana knows why the voice sounds familiar. And you can hear her take it in. The person she was talking to was her cousin. The two hadn't seen each other in a long time. And her cousin didn't seem to realize
你叫什么名字？我的名字是比尔。哔。我的姓是哔。现在，罗沙娜知道为什么这个声音听起来很熟悉了。你能听到她倒吸了一口气。她正在交谈的人是她的表妹。两人已经很长时间没见了。而她的表妹似乎并没有意识到
she was talking to Urshana. Okay, one moment. She puts her cousin on hold and turns to her co-workers. Oh my God, she tells them. This is my cousin. When she gets back on the call, she seems not to know what to say at all. Like she's lost the script completely. Okay. Okay, so let me um finally she recovers a bit and makes her way through her usual screening questions, trying to determine if her cousin meets the definition of
她正在跟罗沙娜说话。好的，请稍等。她让表妹保持通话，然后转向同事。天哪，她对他们说。这是我的表妹。当她重新接听电话时，她似乎完全不知道该说些什么。就像她完全忘词了一样。好的。好的，那么让我……最后她稍微恢复过来，开始走她常规的筛选流程，试图确定她的表妹是否符合
literal homelessness. Where did you sleep last night, et cetera? usual screening questions, trying to determine if her cousin meets the definition of literal homelessness. Where did you sleep last night, etc.? And... The only friend there family could stay with. Yeah. This is the point, Roshanna wants to tell her cousin it's her, but she can't figure out how to say it. It's now nine minutes into the call, and she's finished with the screening interview. Okay, so you have been determined to be literally homeless by the Alvamina County guidelines.
字面意义上的无家可归的定义。你昨晚睡在哪儿，等等？常规的筛选流程，试图确定她的表妹是否符合字面意义上的无家可归的定义。你昨晚睡在哪儿，等等？还有……唯一能去借宿的朋友或家人。对。就是这个时候，罗沙娜想告诉表妹是她，但她不知道该怎么说出口。通话已经进行到第九分钟，筛选访谈已经结束。好的，根据阿拉米达县的准入准则，你已被确定为字面意义上的无家可归。
You have been determined to be literally homeless. Rjana tells her cousin there's one space available in a shelter in Oakland that she could go to right away. And she can also go and do an assessment, get into the system, which might open up other resources. And that's your first potential steps to getting housed. Okay, so you have busy traveling for I could start taking the first step to the popular get house and maybe open it.
你已被确定为字面意义上的无家可归。罗沙娜告诉表妹，奥克兰的一家庇护所还有一个空位，她可以立刻过去。她还可以去进行评估，进入系统，这可能会解锁其他资源。那是你获得住房的潜在第一步。好的，所以你一直在旅行，我可以开始采取第一步去获得住房，也许能打开局面。
Yeah, will you talk to, will you, it's nothing's immediate, it's gonna take a minute. Okay, so, um, do this shelter, how long can I stay in the shelter for? Just a foot. It just depends. It just depends. You can either. Finally, Roshana finds the words. This is tiny. Tiny is Roshana's nickname. This is why I sent her.
是的，你会跟……你会，这不是立刻就能办到的，需要花点时间。好的，那么，嗯，这个庇护所，我可以在庇护所住多久？只是一脚。这得看情况。这得看情况。你可以要么。最后，罗沙娜找到了词。这是蒂妮。蒂妮是罗沙娜的昵称。这就是我派她去的原因。
Disconvibrating right now. You're messing me up right now. Oh, yeah, I'm dead serious. That's crazy. I feel so bad. This is not supposed to happen. We all... We're sure that tells her cousin that while she waits to get something through coordinated entry, she should also call the shelter in Oakland that has available space. I guess I'll take the number two to the one in Oakland. And then...
现在思维都错乱了。你现在把我搞糊涂了。哦，是的，我非常严肃。太疯狂了。我感觉太糟糕了。本不该发生这种事的。我们都……罗沙娜告诉表妹，在等待通过协调准入系统获得住房的同时，她也应该给奥克兰那个有空位的庇护所打电话。我想我会拿这个号码去奥克兰的那家。然后……
All right. Well, hi, tiny. I know. Yeah, man, I've been hard like, yeah. I know, I know. I was talking to the audience guys the other day. For the next few minutes, the two cousins catch up a little, both eluding in vague ways to difficult and complicated family history.
好吧。嗨，蒂妮。我知道。是的，老兄，一直很艰难，对吧。我知道，我知道。我前几天还在跟听众们谈论这个。在接下来的几分钟里，两个表妹叙了叙旧，两人都含糊其辞地暗示了复杂而艰难的家族历史。
Well, it'll get better for you. It definitely, you know, you're, you're seeming still to be a go-getter and this is the way to do it. I mean, you know, At the end of the call, Rishanna transfers her cousin to the place where she can go do the longer interview to get into the coordinated entry system. I'm going to connect you. I got you connected, okay? Okay. I think I'm going to have to get a number down. I'm going to text you, mind, okay? Okay.
好吧，一切都会好起来的。绝对会，你知道的，你看起来依然是个积极进取的人，这才是正确的方法。我是说，你知道的，通话结束时，罗沙娜将表妹转接到了可以进行较长时间访谈的地方，以便进入协调准入系统。我要帮你转接。我帮你连上了，好吗？好的。我想我得把号码记下来。我发短信给你，好吗？好的。
Okay. Okay, I love you. I love you too. All right. Okay. Okay, I love you. I love you too. All right. When I talked to Rishana about that call, I wanted to ask her if she had thought about offering her cousin a place to stay. And I was struggling with how to do it in a way that didn't sound judgmental,
好的。好的，我爱你。我也爱你。好啦。好的。好的，我爱你。我也爱你。好啦。当我跟罗沙娜谈起那通电话时，我想问她是否考虑过给表妹提供一个住处。我一直在纠结该怎么说才能听起来不那么 judgmental（爱评判），
but then she brought it up on her own. And I didn't really want to fully, at that point, extend my hand as a place to stay because, I didn't feel like I was in the position to do that. Roshana said she was relieved that her cousin hadn't asked to stay. I just didn't want to be faced with that because in my heart I would have had the heart that you like, no you can't come here.
但接着她自己主动提起了这件事。我当时其实并不想完全伸出援手提供一个住处，因为我觉得自己没有处于那种状态。罗沙娜说，她很庆幸表妹没有提出借宿的要求。我只是不想面对那种情况，因为在内心深处，我不得不表现得像，不，你不能来这里。
Roshana had been in this situation before, not with this cousin, but with other people. And she knew, once you invite someone in, you have to be willing to let them stay until they find another situation. And she knew better than anyone, how long that can take in the Bay Area. When Roshana took that call, it was also back when she first started at 211. Back when she still believed there was a good chance
罗沙娜以前也遇到过这种情况，不是和这个表妹，而是和其他人。她知道，一旦你邀请某人进来，你就必须愿意让他们住下来，直到他们找到另一个住处。而她比任何人都清楚，在湾区这需要花多长时间。罗沙娜接听那通电话时，也正是她刚开始在 211 工作的时候。那时她还相信，
that the coordinated entry system could help people like her cousin. These days, she understands better that a lot of people who go into that system don't end up getting anything. And that's what Roshana's cousin told me happened to her. She and her son stayed in hotels for a while over the summer, but she recently managed to get them back into a place of their own. Roshana isn't the only operator at 2-1-1 with second or even first-hand experience with
协调准入系统很有可能帮助像她表妹这样的人。如今，她更清楚地认识到，许多进入该系统的人最终什么也没得到。而罗沙娜的表妹告诉我，她就是这样的遭遇。她和儿子在夏天去酒店住了一段时间，但她最近设法让他们搬回了自己的住所。罗沙娜并不是 211 中唯一一个对无家可归有第二手甚至第一手体验的接线员。
homelessness. One operator named Gwen told me she'd been homeless herself for about five years, not that long ago. She slept in cars and hotels when she could. Another Michelle told me she thinks her mother could become homeless soon. It's probably not a coincidence that all the operators who told me they had some kind of experience with homelessness were black. When rents began to release spike, low-income African Americans who were already putting
一个名叫格温（Gwen）的接线员告诉我，不久前她自己也曾无家可归大约五年。她睡在车里，条件允许时住酒店。另一个名叫米歇尔（Michelle）的接线员告诉我，她觉得她母亲不久后也可能会无家可归。所有告诉我某种程度上经历过无家可归的接线员都是黑人，这大概并非巧合。当房租开始急剧飙升时，低收入的非裔美国人原本就已经将大约一半的工资用于支付房租，他们极易陷入无家可归的境地，许多人也确实如此。在奥克兰，
roughly half of their paycheck toward rent were extremely susceptible to becoming homeless and many did. In Oakland, African Americans currently make up 70% of the homeless population and only 24% of the general population. How many people? And the crew? 3554 countries. No, for the crew.
非裔美国人目前占无家可归人口的 70%，而占总人口的比例仅为 24%。有多少人？还有船员？3554 个国家。不，是船员。邮轮上有大约 3500 人，你告诉我。哇，他们在邮轮上。在邮轮上。下午，211 的灾害防范协调员拉尔斯·埃里克霍姆（Lars Erichholm）过来与接线员核对情况。那是 3 月 10 日，就在我待在呼叫中心的头一天，
The crew ship was about 3500 people, give it to me. Wow, they were on the cruise ship. On the cruise ship. In the afternoon, Lars Erichholm, the disaster preparedness coordinator at 2-1-1, comes up to check in with the operators. It was March 10, and the day before I was in the call center, the Grand Princess cruise ship had docked in Oakland to carefully unload several passengers who were sick with COVID-19.
“至尊公主号”邮轮已在奥克兰靠岸，以便小心翼翼地卸下几名感染了新冠病毒的乘客。拉尔斯·埃里克刚刚发布了一份备忘录，其中包含链接和信息，供可能对该病毒有疑问的来电者参考。几周后，211 的接线员不仅要应对关于无家可归和贫困的电话，还要应对关于病毒和相关关停的电话。一个月后，湾区的一个无家可归者庇护所将爆发大规模新冠疫情。
Lars Erich had just sent around a memo with links and information for callers who might have questions about the virus. In a couple weeks, the 2-1-1 operators would have to field calls not only about homelessness and poverty, but about the virus and the associated shutdown. In a month, there would be a major coronavirus outbreak in a homeless shelter in the Bay Area. And some shelters would start operating at a reduced capacity.
一些庇护所将开始减容运营。很快，当人们谈论危机时，他们谈论的将不再是无家可归或住房问题。他们谈论的将是这场大流行。但在那一刻，我们还没有真正意识到。我知道这很多。确实如此，这就是为什么我敞开心扉。但它……你知道这个吗？
And soon when people talked about the crisis, they wouldn't be talking about homelessness or housing anymore. They'd be talking about the pandemic. But at that moment, we didn't really get it yet. I realize this is a lot. And it is, that's why I opened it up close. But it's... You know this?
哇，五个男士床位？五个？第一次。你可能还记得，早些时候哈塔·冈萨雷斯没能为庇护所里的母亲和孩子找到一个以上的空位，但她刚刚收到了奥克兰一家庇护所的最新消息。等等，你能说发生了什么吗？我们有五个男士床位。
Wow, five male beds? Five? First time. You probably remember that earlier Hata Gonzales had not been able to find more than one space for a mother and child in a shelter, but she's just gotten an update from a shelter in Oakland. Wait, can you say what happened? We have five male beds.
这有点像……能有这么多很罕见。我们通常只有……有时甚至没有。所以我们有一个或两个。总的来说，在过去 15 年左右的时间里，联邦资金已经从庇护所等事物转向了住房等更永久性的解决方案。在一个估计至少有 8,000 名无家可归者、可能还不止的县里，只有五个开放的庇护所床位并不理想。
And that's kind of like rare to have that many. We only have like a Sunday's nothing. So we have one or two on it. In general, over the last 15 years or so, federal funding has shifted away from things like shelters and toward more permanent solutions like housing. Five open shelter beds in a county that estimates there are at least 8,000 homeless people, and probably many more is not ideal.
尽管如此，五个开放的庇护所床位就是接线员实际帮助来电者的五次机会，每个人都很兴奋。嗨，里思先生。嗯，你今天的透析做完了吗？在一天快结束时，大约下午 5 点，罗沙娜接到了一位需要其中一张床位的来电者。她准备好了。她实际上有东西可以提供，因为还剩下几个床位。
Still, five open shelter beds is five chances for the operators to actually help their callers, and everyone's excited. Hi, Mr. Reese. Um, are you done with your dialysis for the day? At the very end of the day, around 5 p.m., Roshanna gets a color who needs one of those five beds. She's ready. She actually has something to offer because there are still a couple left.
只是，出了个问题。这位客户在跨城的肾透析中心。他需要在下午 6 点前赶到庇护所。不，不，不，不，六点，六点，对，今晚六点。目前大约是五点过十分。那里有人吗？不，冷静点。冷静点。没关系。那里有人吗？愿意载你一程的？这位来电者名叫詹姆斯·里思（James Reese），他当时慌了神。如果他不能进入庇护所，他担心自己今晚得睡在外面。这里没有人，这里没有人。帮帮我。根本没有。
Only, there's a problem. The client is a cross-town at kidney dialysis center. And he needs to be at the shelter by 6 p.m. No, no, no, no, six, six, yeah, six tonight. It's currently around 10 minutes after five. Is there anyone there? No, calm down. Calm down. It's okay. Is there anyone there? That would be willing to give you a ride? This caller, his name is James Reese, was panicking. If he couldn't get into the shelter, he worried he'd have to sleep outside that night. No one here, there's no one here. Help me. At all.
你不能说不能。我的能力就在那儿，不是吗？我被困住了。嗯……嗯，让我，让我把你置于短暂保持通话状态，看看我能为交通做点什么，好吗？211 接线员其实没有预算来协助来电者的交通。但罗沙娜告诉我，有一个针对 Lyft 乘车的非常小的基金。不过这本应只用于去杂货店和看医生的行程。我知道那笔资金非常严格，他们告诉我们要对此非常严格。里思先生，你甚至连坐公交车回家的办法都没有吗？不，我真的在努力争取帮助，我非常感激你。
You can't say he can't. My ability is just in that, isn't it? I'm stuck. Um... Um, let me, let me place you on a quick hold to see what I can do about transportation, okay? The 211 operators don't really have a budget to help callers with transportation. But there is this very small fund, Rishanna tells me, for lift rides. It's only supposed to be for rides to the grocery store and doctor's appointments though. I know that that funding is very strict and they tell us to be very strict with it. You don't have a way to even take the bus home mysteries? No, I really do that as a help trying to help me and I appreciate you so much.
好的，请稍等。我真是感激不尽。好的，我这就处理。罗沙娜让里思先生重新保持保持通话，并在电脑上打开了 Lyft 应用。她眉头紧锁。她的光标悬停在“请求叫车”按钮上。她对我说：“所以，这就是人性体现的地方。”
Okay, one moment. And I'm just preaching so much. OK, I'll win on that. Roshanna puts Mr. Reese back on hold and opens the app for lift on her computer. Her brow is furrowed. Her cursor is hovering over the request ride button. She says to me, so this is where the humanity comes into it.
起初我并没完全理解，但后来我懂了。一整天下来，就是：你符合标准吗？拨打号码，照本宣科，走流程。但此时此刻，她得以作为一个有人情味的人，而不是一个官僚。好的，嗯，里思先生，给你叫一辆 Lyft，好吗？好的。好的。里思先生有 40 分钟的时间赶到庇护所。
Which I don't really understand at first, but then I get it. Most of the day, it's, do you fit the criteria or not? Call the number, read the script, go through the protocols. But right now she gets to be a human instead of a bureaucrat. Okay um, Mr. Reese, gonna get you a lift, right? Okay. Okay. Mr. Reece has 40 minutes to get to the shelter.
在交通拥堵的情况下，这是一段 30 分钟的车程。三分钟内会有一位名叫里卡多（Ricardo）的司机来接你。他开着一辆白色的本田雅阁。好的。好的。我再过来。我一会儿见。祝你晚安。
It's a 30 minute ride with traffic. You'll be getting picked up in three minutes by a Ricardo. He's driving a white Honda Accord. Okay. Okay. I'll come in again. I'll be seeing you in a while. Have a good night.
再见。好的，好的。我一会儿见。祝你晚安。再见。罗沙娜挂断了电话。但在她的电脑屏幕上，我们可以看到司机里卡多已经开到了里思先生给的地址。但他却只是坐在那里。为什么里卡多会只是坐在那里？也许里思先生根本不在车里。
Bye-bye. Okay, okay. I'll be seeing you in a little while. Have a good night. Bye-bye. Roshanna hangs up the phone. But on her computer screen, we can see that Ricardo, the driver, has pulled up to the address Mr. Ries gave. But he's just sitting there. Why would Ricardo just be sitting there? Maybe Mr. Ries wasn't actually in the car.
他在等。他要走了。喂？嗨，里思先生。他在等。他要走了。喂？嗨，里思先生。他在那儿。好的。嘿，我出来了。我马上就出来。好的，你可能得快点。好的。好的。你是那辆车。谢谢。里思先生，他现在已经离开，行程被取消了。
He's waiting. He's going to leave. Hello? Hi, Mr. Ries. He's waiting. He's going to leave. Hello? Hi, Mr. Rees. He's there. Okay. Hey, I'm coming out. I'm coming out right here. Okay, you may want to hurry. Okay. Okay. You're the car. Thank you. Mr. Rees, he's now left and the ride was canceled.
哈？不，不，我在这儿。里思先生，请稍等。她让他重新保持通话。我不确定她是否能再给他叫一辆车，或者那是他仅有的机会。现在是 5 点 30 分。他已经迟到了，但也许还不算太晚。罗沙娜再次操作。一辆绿色的丰田普锐斯将在六分钟内来接你。
Huh? No, no, I'm right here. Hold on one second, Mr. Lee. She puts him back on hold. I'm not sure if she's going to get him another lift or if that was his one chance. It's 5.30. He'd already be late, but maybe not too late. Roshanna this again. Robelle and a grain Toyota Prius will be picking you up in six minutes.
哦天哪，喂。里思先生，我还在这儿。哦，好的，好的。我会一直陪着你，直到你上那辆车。我们在电话里等待罗贝拉（Robella）赶到那里。还有五分钟。来不及了。还是要迟到。
Oh gosh, hello. I'm still here in Mysteries. Oh, okay, okay. And just stay on with you until you get in that car. We wait on the phone while Robella makes his way there. Five more minutes. It's not gonna make it. It's still be late.
随着时间流逝，里思先生紧张地吹起了口哨。车快来吧。哦，他到了。他在等你，绿色的丰田普锐斯。好的，里思先生，你可能得四处走走，找找那辆绿色的丰田普锐斯。快，我们去找那辆车。对，这样你就能上车了。我们可以看到司机的蓝色圆点在屏幕上悬停，绕着街区转圈。里思先生的时间不多了，但他们似乎找不到彼此。好的，我来试着给司机打个电话。请稍等。请接听，罗贝拉。喂。
Mr. Ries whistles nervously as time passes. Come on, car. Oh, he's there. he's waiting for you green Toyota Prius. Okay Mr. Reese you may have to walk around and look for green Toyota Prius. Come on let's look for the vehicle. Yes so you can get in there. We can see the driver's blue dot hovering on the screen circling the block. Mr. Reese is running out of time, but they don't seem to be finding each other. Okay, let me try to call the driver. Hold on one second. Please answer Robelle. Hello.
嗨，罗贝拉。在罗沙娜、里思先生以及 Lyft 司机罗贝拉之间的三方通话中，又进行了四分钟痛苦的来回沟通。里思先生在描述地标，描述自己的外貌。终于，他们找到了彼此。你在车里吗？太完美了。你可能会迟到几分钟，但只要冷静地解释说有人叫你来的就行。她挂断了电话，我们俩靠向椅背，长舒了一口气。太好了。他在路上了。喂。对。很好。他在路上了。
Hi, Robelle. There are four more agonizing minutes of back and forth on a conference call between Roshana and Mr. Ries and Robelle the lift driver. Mr. Ries is describing landmarks, describing himself. Finally, they find each other. You're in the car? Perfect. You're going to be a few minutes late, but just calmly explain that you were told to come. He thinks she hangs up and we both lean back and exhale. So good. He's on his way. Hello. Yeah. Good. That's on his way.
好吧，对。太好了。这算是一件好事。我想这就是让你坚持下去的动力。即使今晚只有一个人能在室内有个容身之处，也会觉得：太好了。我今天干完了。我收工了。我收工了。
Well, yeah. Good. That's a good thing. I guess that's what keeps you going. Even if it's one person that gets a place inside tonight, it's like, good. And I'm done for the day. I'm out. I'm out.
连午饭都没吃。把里思先生送到那个庇护所是今天结束前一件切实可行的事情。有一个人是罗沙娜可以确凿知道今晚不会露宿街头的人，至少部分原因是因为她。事情并不总是这样。很多时候，这些接线员必须扮演那个告诉人们没有帮助的声音。他们需要的东西根本不存在，而且他们对此无能为力。在做这篇报道之前，我并没有过多地考虑过这一点，但官僚体制不仅
No lunch. Getting Mr. Reese to that shelter was one tangible thing before the day's end. One person who was shana knew for sure wouldn't sleep outside that night, at least partly because of her. It doesn't always go like that. A lot of the time, these operators have to be the voice that tells people there isn't help. The thing they need doesn't exist, and there's nothing they can do to change that. I hadn't thought about it that much before this reporting, but bureaucracies aren't just
对那些试图适应它的人来说是令人沮丧的。对在其中工作的人来说，同样也是令人沮丧的。没有人真正拥有任何代理权，没有权力做出一个真正能帮到某人的决定。所有接线员都告诉我，最好的电话、最好的日子，就是当你觉得自己确实能提供点什么的时候。很多时候你并没有。很多时候你觉得你所做的一切只是把人转手，好让他们被塞进一个名单。是的，阿拉米达县确实有一个大型的无家可归者总名单，
frustrating for the people trying to navigate them. They're frustrating for the people working inside of them too. No one really has any agency, no power to make a decision that could really help someone. All the operators told me that the best calls, the best days, or when you feel like you actually had something to offer. A lot of the time you don't. A lot of the time you feel like all you're doing is passing people off to be put on a list. And yes, there is actually one big master list of homeless people in Alameda County,
但只有当你排到最前面时，你才能得到住房方面的帮助。我了解了这个名单是如何运作的，以及为什么蒂莱西亚从未获得任何住房方面的帮助。但首先，我们究竟是如何得出这样的看法的：如果有人无家可归，他们需要的就是一间房子。因为现在听起来这可能是显而易见的，但过去并非总是如此。请听下一集的“按需分配”。
but you only get help with housing if you get to the top of it. I learned all about how this list works and why Tuleisha never got any help with housing. But first, how did we even arrive at the idea that if someone is homeless, what they need is a house. Because it might sound obvious now, but it wasn't always that way. That's next time on According to Need.
片花过后。下一集的“按需分配”。我到处睡觉。我睡在富兰克林·罗斯福大道下的一个纸板箱里。我想那就在桥底下。有一种意识，无论这是什么，无论我们对这群人试图做什么，它都行不通。哦，是的，我以前经常打架。
After the break of preview. Next time on According to Need. I slept all over the place. I slept in a cardboard box under the FDR drive. I think that was right under the bridge. There was like an awareness that whatever this is, whatever we're trying to do with this population, it's not working. Oh yeah, I used to fight a lot.
一遇到一堆狗屁倒灶的事，我的脾气就变得很急躁。我们的申请人屡次未通过住房面试。我们无法说服住房提供者接收任何人。我们惨败了。我感觉真的很糟糕。我希望我能戒掉这些毒品。如果人们流落街头，你永远无法进行那些对话，因为一切都围绕着：我今晚要睡哪儿，我要吃什么，你知道的，我安全吗。
I do got a short tempo when it comes to a bunch of bocrap. Our applicants repeatedly failed the housing interviews. We could not persuade housing providers to take anybody. We were failing miserably. I felt really bad. I wish I could get off these drugs. If people are on the street, you're never going to be able to have those conversations, because it's all about, where am I going to sleep, and what am I going to eat, and you know, like am I safe.
斯兰告诉我们，公寓说越早签租约越好。他们很喜欢这个想法：他们可以在一栋普通大楼里拥有自己的住所，而不会被识别为居住在某个项目里。这是一个极好的卖点。这是一个极好的卖点。这是一个梦想。所以，你知道的，我们就顺其自然了。几十年前，纽约市的一场实验彻底颠覆了帮助人们摆脱无家可归的剧本。
Sland told us that the apartment says I was the sooner we get the leases. They loved the idea that they could have their own place in a regular building and not be identified as living in a program. It was a great seller. He was a great seller. It was a dream. So, you know, we just went with it. A few decades ago, an experiment in New York City flipped the script completely on how to help people out of homelessness.
敬请收听“按需分配”。即将播出“按需分配”。本集的“按需分配”由我凯蒂·明戈尼（Katie Mingle）制作，助理制作人是艾比·马丹（Abby Madan），责任编辑是惠特尼·亨利·莱斯特（Whitney Henry Lester）。罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）担任执行制作人。来自莉萨·波洛克（Lisa Pollock）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）和罗曼·马尔斯的宝贵编辑意见。布伦丹·贝克（Brendan Baker）担任我们的声音工程师，艾米·盖恩斯（Amy Gaines）负责事实核查，美丽的音乐由美丽的肖恩·拉尔（Sean Rall）创作，品牌与设计由 muchmore.io 负责。库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）担任我们的数字总监，索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sofia Klatsker）、维维安·李（Vivian Leigh）和克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）提供额外支持。
That's coming up on according to need. coming up on According to Need. This chapter of According to Need was produced by me, Katie Mingle, with associate producer Abby Madan and managing editor Whitney Henry Lester. Roman Mars was the executive producer. In valuable editing from Lisa Pollock, Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, and Roman Mars. Brendan Baker was our sound engineer, fact checking by Amy Gaines, beautiful music by the beautiful Sean Raell, branding and design by muchmore.io. Kurt Colstead was our digital director, additional support from Sofia Klatsker, Vivian Leigh and Chris Baroube.
这些内容将在《按需分配》中播出。《按需分配》的这一集由我凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）制作，副制作人是艾比·马丹（Abby Madan），执行主编是惠特尼·亨利·莱斯特（Whitney Henry Lester）。罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）担任执行制作人。丽莎·波洛克（Lisa Pollock）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）和罗曼·马尔斯提供了宝贵的编辑意见。布伦丹·贝克（Brendan Baker）是我们的录音师，艾米·盖恩斯（Amy Gaines）负责事实核查，美丽的音乐由肖恩·拉尔（Sean Raell）创作，品牌和设计由muchmore.io负责。科特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是我们的数字总监，索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sofia Klatsker）、维维安·利（Vivian Leigh）和克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）提供了额外支持。
Special thanks to all the people who spoke to me for this series, as well as Marisol Medina Carina, Alison De Young, Johanna Zorn, and Chelsea Miller. According to Need is a project of 99% invisible, which is a founding proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a network of independent listener-supported, artist-owned podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
特别感谢所有接受本系列采访的人，以及玛丽索尔·梅迪纳·卡里娜、艾莉森·德扬、乔安娜·佐恩和切尔西·米勒。“按需分配”是 99% Invisible 的一个项目，该节目是 PRX 旗下 Radio Topia 的骄傲创始成员，Radio Topia 是一个由听众资助、艺术家拥有的独立播客网络。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。